you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
july is confirmed as earth's hottest
month ever recorded
we reveal the oil companies paying
negative tax on their north sea
operations
and meet the woman growing tea to save a
rainforest in paraguay
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
july 2021 was the hottest month ever
recorded on earth according to data
released by the united states the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration described it as the
disturbing and disruptive path that
climate change has set for the globe
well let's talk to our correspondent
charlotte lomas now so charlotte an
uncomfortable milestone reached then in
july
it is anna this is according to data as
you mentioned there from noaa the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration and they found that the
global surface temperature for july was
the hottest since records began in 1880
now the agency measured the combined
land and ocean surface temperature and
found it to be
0.93 degrees celsius above the 20th
century average of 15.8
degrees they also gave a breakdown
regionally and found that asia was
leading the way had the hottest july
ever and europe had its second hottest
july ever and experts have described
this as adding to the disturbing and
disruptive path that climate change has
set
charlotte thank you
well red alert heat warnings have been
issued across italy as southern europe
continues to experience a severe heat
wave so let's take a look at what's
happening today and this is the eu's
emergency monitoring system now it
forecasts fire danger levels based on
meteorological predictions and you can
see here that large areas of turkey
greece albania and southern italy as
well are dark purple now these areas are
most at risk of fire and it's the same
for north macedonia spain and portugal
as well as tunisia now if you look at
the red dots they show where they've
been active fires just in the last 24
hours
well while wildfires are a common
occurrence there's a very specific link
to our changing climate which is known
as the climate feedback loop now
increase global emissions lead to higher
temperatures which cause milder winters
and longer summers now these conditions
leave forests full of dried out and dead
vegetation which acts as fuel now that
means that man-made and natural fires
start easily and spread quickly
now when forests burn trees release
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere and that
increased amount of carbon accelerates
global warming
pushing temperatures up even further and
causing that cycle to continue
now in the town of tivoli east of rome
residents have been forced to evacuate
after a fire broke out in rome it's one
of hundreds of fires that are continuing
to rage across southern italy
and the fires are burning in the u.s too
these pictures show the extent of the
devastation in northern california the
dixie fire has burned around 75 percent
of the historical town of greenville
destroying hundreds of buildings and
forcing residents to flee their homes
and it's still threatening several small
towns in the sierra nevada with only 30
percent of that fire contained
meanwhile in turkey severe floods and
mudslides have killed 27 people and one
other person is still missing now more
than 1 700 people have been evacuated
from the black sea coastal provinces of
barton casta monu synop and samsung and
hundreds have been rescued by
helicopters aisha zarhid has been
looking at the reasons behind the severe
rainfall
turkey is on the front line of a
disaster triggered by the changing
climate
flooding in the northern region has
destroyed homes and claimed lives
thousands have been forced to evacuate
this is the most severe flood disaster
that i have ever seen both in terms of
area that was affected and its severity
despite suffering repeated extreme
weather events turkey remains the only
g20 country not to ratify the paris
climate agreement
a summer of record-breaking temperatures
contributed to this deluge
when air heats up it holds more moisture
so every time the temperature increases
by 1 degree celsius
moisture in the air can increase by 7
percent
this water has to go somewhere and
that's why we see increases in intense
rainstorms
when we look at the events that we are
having at the moment in turkey these are
events that
are not have been seen before certain
countries are in much worse shape like
bangladesh or india or pakistan all of
these countries
will have
worse problems than the average of the
world but nobody is spared
more events like this are inevitable
what's important to consider now is how
we prepare for them
aisha zahid sky news
in today's other climate news a glacier
on italy's side of mont blanc is at risk
of collapse which scientists say is a
result of climate change the planned
pancreas glacier reached its melting
point a decade ago and since then rising
temperatures have caused the ice mass to
move from its once secure position on
the mont blanc massive the glacier now
rests on a smoother part of the mountain
putting the valve ray valley below at
risk
footballer morton thorsby is switching
his shirt number in an effort to raise
awareness of climate change the
midfielder who plays for the italian
team sampdoria normally sports number 18
but has swapped it for a number two he
says the number represents the paris
agreement target of keeping global
temperatures well below two degrees
above pre-industrial levels
and earlier this year the uk government
launched a 500 million pound blue planet
fund to support countries on the front
line of climate change and today it's
been announced that 16.2 million pounds
from that fund will be invested in five
projects that focus on protecting the
ocean
however greenpeace's head of oceans says
the government isn't doing enough to
protect uk waters
we've been out at sea for the last few
months in the channel and inside our
marine protected areas we've seen
everything from illegal fishing to
destructive bottom trawling to super
trawlers over a hundred meters long the
uk if it wants to be a global leader it
wants to be seen to be a world leader in
ocean protection it has to do
the work at home to protect its
protected areas as well as the work that
it's doing overseas
some of the world's biggest oil
companies are currently paying negative
tax in the uk on some north sea
operations
data shows in the tax year 2019 to 20
exxon mobil received 117 million pounds
in total from hmrc
shell got 110 million pounds and bp
received 39 million and they're not
alone our climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter has more
this situation is possible because of a
uk tax policy that was actually brought
in around the time of the climate of the
paris climate change
agreement that allows oil companies
working in the north sea uh to claim
public money in order to help them with
the costs of decommissioning their rigs
and infrastructure uh and
tens and of millions of pounds hundreds
of millions actually have been paid uh
by hmrc to these big oil companies since
the tax policy
came into force um the uk oil and gas
authority actually estimates that the
total cost of decommissioning these rigs
as the uk advances towards its net zero
targets in 2050 is going to be about 51
billion pounds and because of this uk
tax policy the british taxpayer is on
the hook for nearly 40 percent of that
uh the treasury has estimated that the
cost to ex to the exchequer up until
about
uh 2065 is going to be some 18 billion
pounds so a lot of money at stake
campaigners say that this basically
amounts to the british taxpayer
subsidizing fossil fuels effectively uh
and that the uk
should in fact be assuming a kind of
moral and practical leadership position
in the months before it hosts the cop 26
uh climate change conference um but
we've had lots of responses from the
companies
involved and uh also from the treasury
and they've given us some statements
treasury spokesperson told sky news that
the uk oil and gas industry has paid
around 375 billion pounds in production
taxes to date relief for decommissioning
costs is a fundamental part of the uk's
tax system contributing to the safe
removal of oil oil and gas
infrastructure from our natural
environment while ensuring companies are
encouraged to invest in the uk and a
spokesperson from exxon
mobile said that over the lifetime of
the north sea we have been a major net
contributor to the tax revenues
generated by the basin and the recent
refunds simply represent a repayment of
some prior paid taxes some of our older
fields enter the decommissioning phase
of their life
similarly a spokesperson
for shell has said that decommissioning
is part of the life cycle of oil fields
this phase of work is heavily regulated
and subject to tax legislation that
enables tax relief the concept of
granting tax relief for genuine business
expenses is fundamental to regimes that
tax profits
and a spokesperson for bp said that the
data in question only covers the
extractive part of our business in the
uk our north sea business and bp has
contributed over 40 billion in taxes to
the uk government with respect to its
north sea businesses
we can get more details and comments
from the companies and the treasury on
our website just head to skynews.com
climate
the atlantic forest in south america was
once one of the largest rainforests in
the world covering more than 200 million
acres of land now just 20 percent
remains one woman who's working to
restore the area is fabiana benitez
she's part of a team of conservationists
who are growing tea to help biodiversity
there
so since i was a kid i want to be
involved in biodiversity
san rafael is one of the most important
atlantic forest remnant in paraguay and
we are facing
a lot of threats
from illegal logging wildfires hunting
encroachment
and other illegal activities
and how do we do this job using yerba
mate
yoramata is a native plant of the
atlantic forest it's part of our
identity as paraguayans and is globally
known as tea
[Music]
one hectare of these productive systems
is one hectare gained for the atlantic
forest and one hectare to generate
incomes for the rural and indigenous
communities and improve their
livelihoods
[Music]
well that's everything from us today but
don't forget to check out the weekly
climate show and in the latest episode
find out how climate change could affect
your sex life you can find that on the
sky news snapchat channel
and in this week's episode of
climatecast we look at what the world
and its leaders need to do to slow
climate change following the ipcc report
that's out now wherever you normally get
your podcast from thanks for watching
see you next week
[Music]